Mary here again to talk to you about the
latest games in new releases and this
week [ __ ] just goat serious coffee stain
studios created one of the most insane
games in years for you to play and tell
the world calm down everyone I goat this
all right it takes about 10 of 15 hours
to bleep coming out on pc eat pans
frolic cause mischief whatever floats
your goat get your goat on April first
this week you get to visit Blackgate
prison and hang out with some of your
best friends in batman arkham origins
blackgate deluxe edition Oh value guest
the team behind the handheld version
armature studio offers the same story of
Black Gate but in high definition and
fancy new bat skins so you can look good
for Catwoman this is shaping up to be a
long night the romance begins April
first also this week you get to create
your own Empire and rule the land age
wonders 3 smite your enemies and claim
your lands and strategic turn-based
hexagon battlegrounds attack when you're
ready or be surprised attacking a
neighboring City outsmart them to save
the day webex asian duck please on fire
become a dorvan theocrat march 31st
the beta has concluded and the elder
scrolls online crashes onto pc with all
its cinematic glory the massive
multiplayer role-playing game is set in
Tamriel as the other Elder Scrolls games
the game will be set a millennium before
the events Skyrim and around eight
hundred years before moro wind and
Oblivion but rest assured there will be
plenty of skeletons to kill on your
rings April fourth and finally take a
swing with MLB 14 the show this comes
out first of April for ps3 and Vita
owners but ps4 owners have to wait until
May easy dude for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week